let's jump into this story here's the
big breaking news
it's a scoop so saith axios tucker
carlson
sought putin interview at time of spying
claim
that's that's it right there let now for
those not familiar with the story let me
just rehash real quickly for those are
just tuning in
tugger carlson came out on his show and
said someone revealed to him
information that was in his texts and
his emails that no one else had access
to
this long story short said to him the
nsa was spying on
on him and his communications this is
what was conveyed to him he said the
intent was to leak it
to get his show taken off the air as
soon as he comes out and says this
of course all the conservatives say i
trust tucker i don't think he's going to
make this up
not even just conservatives just you
know anti-establishment types and of
course the establishment immediately
said
he's making it up he's lying he's bsing
he's not being spied on and the nsa
themselves issued what's called a
non-denial denial
where they said tucker's claim that
we're trying to get his show taken off
the air is untrue
perhaps semantics but they never
outright denied that they intercepted
his communications
and tucker said he pressed them so or
him or one of his staff said
are you reading our emails and they
refuse to issue a response
all of a sudden a story comes out that
tucker was going to try and interview
vladimir putin
which means the story did get leaked
from who
i'd have to imagine tucker was right it
was the nsa jonathan swan of axios can
just reveal who his source is
he says tucker carlson was talking to
us-based kremlin intermediaries about
setting up an interview with vladimir
putin
shortly before the fox news host accused
the nsa of spying on him
sources familiar with the conversations
tel axios
now how are they familiar with those
conversations if tucker says he didn't
share them with anybody
is the source actually someone at fox
news who's stabbed tucker in the back
no the person that tucker claims unless
unless okay of course you can still say
tucker's
a liar but tucker preempted this think
about what would have happened if tucker
never said anything
the story right now would be leaked
communications show tucker trying to
negotiate deals with vladimir putin or
something to that effect
instead because tucker came out and said
he was working on a story
the narrative is now while tucker was
claiming to be working on a story
he was talking to people who are kremlin
intermediaries
i think he he ripped the fangs out i
think he calmed this one down it was a
smart move
and they dragged him over it now the
funny thing is all these journalists
that are trying to act like it's oh oh
i'm a serious reporter oh this
it must be true even though they were
the ones dragging him the whole time
that's what you can expect man right
man i'm a journalist my number one job
is to go to the source my number one job
is to get the best interview possible
who would be a better interviewee than a
leader
of one of the u.n security council
members
the leader of their country vladimir
putin i i'm interested to
to examine a little bit more deeply the
timing of this it says here that they
were talking
to putin now it's about him trying to
get an interview with putin now
so this is in real time this isn't this
isn't even uh
trump is in office this isn't even
during trump
russia scandal or whatnot this is just
tucker carlson going about his normal
business as a journalist who interviews
top leading world officials
and they snared him in their
international spy ring that's
coordinated against
multiple or coordinated with multiple
different english-speaking countries
five eyes right
and they they were like hey we need to
figure out who this guy is so they took
him to a fisa court they made a case
right they had to make a case to a
special judge
to say this is why we should be able to
figure out who this american citizen is
and and nick what could the case have
been
this guy wants to talk to putin oh
he must be a guy if it's the nsa and
i don't think tucker's lying on this one
we've got his claim the story gets
leaked
it also makes sense it's not like the
nsa has come out and said here's the
evidence we did it
but it's all lined up so i'll i'll put
it there i would say
it's beyond a reasonable doubt in my
opinion but to be fair there's a
probability that tucker is wrong about
who's leaking or he was misled
somebody at fox may have leaked it axios
says axios has not confirmed whether any
communications from carlson have been
intercepted
and if so why that think about what that
means
what's with this weird double speak why
can't axio say
axios has not confirmed whether any
communications from carlson
were or i'm sorry why can't they say
they have not confirmed
that the nsa was the source of this
information
what they're saying was his
communications have been intercepted
so that means the the source for
jonathan swann may actually be the nsa
but the nsa didn't say we spied on
tucker just hears information on tucker
if here's the point when the nsa denied
spying on tucker they never came out
right and said we are not reading his
emails we are not reading his
texts that's not true they said tucker
alleged that we were spying on his
communications and were planning to leak
them in order to get a show off the air
that allegation is untrue
well the the allegation in that sentence
is the final uh right
subject to get his show off the air
right which could have been hyperbolic
or they could have been like we wanted
to damage him
not get him canceled just hurt him
enough that maybe eventually he does
who knows they can argue a million a
million ways why that wasn't true
but they never said we did not intercept
communications from tucker carlson we
are not
spying on him either accidentally or on
purpose right they gave someone weird
double speak or
incidentally right incidentally right
which is actually like the key word in
this case right
because it's really about them spying on
putin
and they incidentally have discovered
that there's an american citizen
involved therefore now
this internationally focused spy agency
can now turn their attention this is all
congruent with everything we've been
talking about here for months and months
and months and months and months the war
on terror coming home coming home right
extremists
dude we've been saying this from for
what how long check check this out they
said 2003
2006. exio says those sources said u.s
government officials
learned about carlson's effort to secure
the putin interview how
carlson learned the government was aware
of his outreach and that's the basis of
his extraordinary accusation
followed by a rare public denial by the
nsa that he has been targeted wait wait
wait wait wait wait hold on hold on
sources have literally said carlson
learned the government was aware of his
outreach
he's basically confirming there's a
federal agency in some capacity somehow
that was aware of his outreach what
they're saying is is
the government is spying on you tucker
why are you crying about it no one's
someone's object
objecting to the spying right right
they're objecting to the crowning now i
want to go back to this statement from
axios
they have can they have not confirmed
whether any communication from carlson
have been intercepted and if so why not
confirmed
that the sentence literally means
nothing so an nsa guy goes to jonathan
swan hypothetically
and says hey you know you know tucker
carlson is uh trying to meet with putin
i can confirm that to you right now 100
guaranteed
and swan says how do you know that don't
worry about it okay i can't confirm they
were spying on him but he told me that
if it wasn't the nsa telling jonathan
swann why didn't they also add the
source of this information is not coming
from the nsa no
they're quite literally saying carlson
learned from the government was aware
us government officials had learned
about this who with access to the
government
was providing information to jonathan
swann that is an interesting question
because
it does suggest that there's a white hat
and a black hat
in operation right now right somebody
telling tucker
and somebody talking to swan at the same
time is it two different people is it
the same person
they go on to say but let me read a
little bit of this the nsa's public
statement didn't directly deny that any
carlson communications had been swept up
by the agency
axios submitted a request for comment to
the nsa on wednesday
asking whether the agency would also be
willing to categorically deny that the
nsa intercepted any of carlson's
communications
in the context of monitoring somebody he
was talking to in his effort to set up
an interview with putin
an nsa spokesperson declined to comment
and referred axios back to the earlier
statement
carefully worded it says in other words
the nsa is denying the targeting of
carlson but is not denying that his
communications were incidentally
collected
and axios is not telling us who their
source is
whether or not their sources is part of
the nsa and they could do that
if i if i had a source who revealed that
jack murphy had stolen my cookies from
the cookie jar
and people were like ian was the source
i could be like ian was not the source
i can confirm that much right right
lydia witnessed
jack and i said i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna out my source you know
but i can certainly say it wasn't ian
that's one person out of the million it
could have been
they could just say our source is not
the nsa
what is not in government what is axios
who what horse do they ride in here
what do they want to see have happen i
don't know
how do they slant how do they lean how
do they dress as the tailor asks
i mean jonathan swann he's the guy who
did that really awful interview with
trump where he was just negative about
literally everything trump said
and he was scowling the whole time at
everything trump said
look we know that they were they are
literally searching
right now oliver dumb dumb darcy
and team they're all searching for who's
the next putin
who's the next hitler who's next who's
the next trump
who's the next evil guy that we have to
destroy
and isn't it funny that the timing on
all this just happened right now
tucker carlson is being named as you
know if tucker hadn't gotten out in
front
of this what would the story have been
story had been
tucker carlson trying to collude
secretly with vladimir putin
he's the russian gate 2.5 yes so so we
already saw
this absolutely hilarious story
where brian stelter in his pathetic
desperate attempt for ratings so for
those aren't familiar he's a guy who
hosts
sunday mornings on cnn it's a little poo
poo show and he was like
on youtube is tucker carlson the new
alex jones
yes and then oliver darcy like tucker
carlson is the new alex jones the funny
thing is oliver never blinked
did you notice that i don't i don't
really notice but a lot of people kept
posting like does this guy blink at all
like he's just standing there staring at
the camera dude's gone nuts
like oliver these these people i wonder
if they
if they like cry at night oliver i know
you're crying dude i
know you're crying well no no but but
think about it like
they've they've dug themselves in so
deep to this anti-trump narrative
that there's nothing they can do they
could they could cut
guys it was a big joke um
nah their careers are done done the only
thing they have left is orange man bad
but there's no orange man anymore
they're trying to find one desperately
tucker carlson is the new alex jones
they said did you see this clip
did you see the clip they did oh with
stultzer and darcy salter and darcy on
the new
jones of course i did because oliver i
love laughing at you by the way
tucker carlson goes he's like there's
risks in everything of course and even
vaccines and then it pauses
and then it's alex jones you know
yelling about the vaccines i'm like
those aren't even the same statements
your doctor will tell you there can be
adverse reactions like
that's normal then there's what do you
say when he mentions the spying
then it shows an old clip from like the
two thousands of jones like they're
spying money on me and it's been
admitted it's happening
and i'm like so you found three or four
things that are
somewhat related but still kind of
different and you're acting like he's
he's verbatim repeating alex jones it
was the most ridiculous
garbage story ever a few months ago
what did they say tucker carlson is the
new donald trump
and they did the same thing showing
tucker
saying things and then trump saying
things and they're like tucker is the
new
trump they've been trying to do that
nonstop
i don't think it has anything to do
necessarily uh with politics though
partly i'm sure a lot of activists don't
lie that tucker carlson is influential
speaking to young people particularly
huge in the writing especially in the
key demo
i think they're just desperate for an
orange man they know they know orange
man no more don't know what to do
they don't know how to to function
unless they've got someone they can
point to and say
hitler hitler hitler hitler hitler and
they're going to try to tie everybody
back to trump because they
they really shot their wad on this you
want you want right like you can't get
any worse than the things that they
called trump
right right so they gotta now call
everybody trump
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you